now before we get started with with all
the important news and everything today
and there's a lot but there's a lot to
cover but I need to and and this is
awkward because I'm here in LA at the
Daily wire studios this week but I need
to air my grievances about someone in
this company I was at dinner last night
with all the writers on the site and it
was it it you know went well except for
I'm not gonna mention any names but
someone put strawberries on their pizza
in my presence and I took a picture of I
put it on Twitter here's the picture
right here justjust Esper strawberries
on pizza
now I suffered a great deal of trauma
witnessing this I did I I'm firmly in
the don't knock it till you try it camp
so I did try it myself and I can report
that strawberries on Pizza tastes like
strawberries on peach that's basically
exactly it tastes as though you have put
strawberries on your pizza it's exactly
what you expect it's disgusting listen I
know that some sociopaths and terrorists
and serial killers will put pineapple on
their pizza that's bad enough but we
have to draw the line somewhere okay we
can't just take the whole bowl of fruit
salad and dump it on the pizza there's
got we've got to draw the line somewhere
and this was just a travesty and I am
gonna be filing a complaint with HR
about that but democratic debate last
night another one it was almost as
revolting as strawberry on pizza we'll
talk about that we'll do some highlights
and then we're gonna move on from the
debate and a couple of things we're
gonna respond to an attack on me and
we've also got to talk about the racist
Reagan tapes that maybe you heard about
last night all right a few moments from
the debate last night the thing that I
think everyone is talking about the most
important moment was Joe Biden
apparently giving the audience some kind
of secret code I don't know if this was
a secret message to the Russians or if
he was these are the coordinates to
buried treasure or maybe this was the
the launch code for a nuclear attack I'm
not sure but something very strange
happened last night at the at the end of
the debate watch this this is the United
States of America we've acted together
we have never never never but not able
to overcome whatever the problem was if
you agree with me go to Joe 303 300 feet
in this fight thank you very much now by
the way if you actually which I did if
you go to Joe
three oh three three oak aam it takes
you to this video
[Music]
hi there I'm Josh Mayer and today I'm
launching my exploratory committee for
the 2020 presidential race now I may be
the youngest candidate by far in this
race but I know I have what it takes I'm
the only candidate currently running on
a no homework in college position now
some say that this type of policy is
unneeded self-serving and then no one
really wants it but my comprehensive
polling has shown irrefutable that
college students support my position so
there you go I can't make heads or tails
of that but that's what happened now
Cory Booker moving on to some of the
other candidates Cory Booker is possibly
the biggest phony in the race which is
obviously quite a statement and I'm
gonna show you what I mean here is
Booker at one point calling for unity
and and in fact III know we talked
yesterday and I said that when I am in
charge of the world if a political
candidate offers an irrelevant anecdote
that a trapdoor will open and they'll be
sent into waters and eaten by sharks
I would I would also add in that
category people at political debates who
call for unity and say you know we all
we all just need to stop the fighting
and forget about this and get together
it's called a debate okay you're
supposed to be you're not supposed to be
unified you're supposed to be arguing
with each other that's literally the
whole point but here is um
cory booker seeming to struggle with the
concept of what a debate is the person
is enjoying this debate most right now
is donald trump as we pick democrats
against each other while he is working
right now to take away america's health
care so you see he's mad at CNN for
pitting democrats against each other
which again is that it's a democrat
debate what do you think they're gonna
do that's like a linebacker you know
being interviewed after the game by a
reporter and complaining that he's sick
and tired of the NFL pitting football
players against each other that's it's
the whole point and cory booker well
understands that because in the very
same debate where he decries democrats
going against each other he also did
this well my response is that this is a
crisis in our country because
we have treated issues of race and
poverty mental health and addiction with
locking people up and not lifting them
up and mr. vice president has said that
since the 1970s every major crime bill
every crime bill major and minor has had
his name on it and so those are your
words not not mine and this is one of
those instances where the house was set
on fire and you claimed responsibility
for those laws and you can't just now
come out with a plan to put out that
fire we have got to have far more bold
action on criminal justice reform we
have a system right now that's broken
and if you want to compare records and
frankly I'm shocked that you do I am
happy to do that because all the
problems that he is talking about that
he created I actually led the bill that
got passed into law that reverses the
damage that your bills that you were
frankly to correct you mr. vice
president you are bragging calling it
the Biden crime bill up to 2000 Thank
You senator T okay so it's we have to
stop pitting Democrats against each
other also FYI Joe Biden is a piece of
crap anyway we need unity so that's
basically what he did there but the two
I think the two headlines from the
debate are the the the trouncing 's
suffered by Camilla Harris and Kirsten
Gillibrand both women who desperately
deserve to be humiliated on stage and
they were so here's Tulsi Gabbard and
probably most talked-about moment
destroying as they say Camilla Harris Oh
senator Harris says she's proud of her
record as a prosecutor and that she'll
be a prosecutor president but I'm deeply
concerned about this record there are
too many examples to cite but she put
over 1500 people in jail for marijuana
violations and then laughed about it
when she was asked if she ever smoked
marijuana she blocked evidence
that would have freed an innocent man
from death row until the courts forced
her to do so
she kept people in prison beyond their
sentences to use them as cheap labor for
the state of California and she fought
to keep bail system in place that
impacts poor people in the worst kind of
way the bottom line is senator Harris
when you are in a position to make a
difference and an impact in these
people's lives you did not and worse yet
in the case of those who were on death
row innocent people you actually blocked
evidence from being revealed that would
have freed them until you are forced to
do so there is no excuse for that and
the people who suffered under your reign
as prosecutor oh you owe them an apology
I am maybe in the minority among
conservatives in that I think Harris
would be a formidable challenge in the
general election for Donald Trump but it
doesn't matter anyway because she ain't
making it to the general election
Democrats simply will not stand for
someone who ever had anything to do with
enforcing the law there they don't want
anything to do with that and when I say
that no it's it's sort of funny that one
of the primary attacks on Kamala Harris
among Democrats is that she is guilty of
having enforced the law when she was
Attorney General but I don't mean that
as a defense of Camille Harris because
she was also and I totally agree with
this she was completely corrupt this is
the person and you're not gonna hear a
Democrat bring this up in a negative way
but this is the same person who as
Attorney General while receiving
donations from Planned Parenthood
launched these that launched attacks on
Planned Parenthood's enemies the Center
for medical progress David daleiden and
the people who were exposing corruption
and Planned Parenthood Camilla Harris is
the one who spearheaded the campaign to
shut them down to legally persecute them
and while doing that she was not only
accepting money from Planned Parenthood
but she had a while she was spearheading
this this this effort as Attorney
General she had a thing on her website
calling people to support and donate to
Planned Parenthood so she was not even
trying to hide
fact that she was operating as a as a
minion of the abortion industry so I
don't I don't weep for Camille Harris at
all and then we had this kerfuffle if I
could call it that
between Biden and Gillibrand now for
context here Gillibrand is trying to hit
by it in for an allegedly sexist op-ed
that he wrote thirty-eight years ago
back in 80 or 81 where he opposed the
bill that I guess would have given tax
breaks to some mothers who send their
kids to daycare and this was sexist
Gillibrand says and here's here's well
let's go right to Biden's response here
it is I was a long time ago here's what
it was about it would have given people
making today $100,000 a year a tax break
for child care I did not want that I
wanted to child care to go to people
making less than $100,000 and that's
what it was about as a single father who
in fact raised three children for five
years by myself I have some idea what a
cost my very beginning my deceased wife
worked but we had children my present
wife has worked all the way through
raising our children I was deeply
involved in all these things I came up
with the it's honest proposal to see to
it the women were treated more decently
on college campuses you came to Syracuse
University with me and said it was
wonderful I'm passionate about the
concern making sure women are treated
equally I don't know what's happened
except that you're now running for
president so I understand
okay so Joe Biden unlike the first
debate has figured out how to respond to
attacks against him forcefully without
being seen as getting down in the mud so
in other words he's figured out how to
be a front-runner which up until now I
don't think he knew how to do that but
now that he's figured that out I think
it's it's bad news for the other
candidates before we move on though I
know I almost forgot I wanted to so
let's let's actually go back let's
rewind a little bit so we just saw
Biden's response which was pretty good I
want to play some of Gillibrand's
original attack on Biden because there's
something she said in there that was
well it was interesting I thought watch
this I think we have to have a broader
conversation about whether we value
women and whether we want to make sure
women have every opportunity in the
workplace and I want to address Vice
President Biden directly when the Senate
was debating middle-class affordability
for childcare he wrote an op-ed he voted
against it the only vote but when he
wrote an op-ed was that he believed that
women working outside the home would
quote create the deterioration of family
he also said that women who were working
outside the home were quote avoiding
responsibility and I just need to
understand as a woman who's worked my
entire career is the primary wage earner
as the primary caregiver
in fact the second my second son Henry
is here all right so stop right there
she says that that she's the she is the
primary caregiver and primary wage
earner in her family she makes that
claim I I mean I I don't even see how
that could be true if you're working
full time you really can't be the
primary caregiver right unless you're
working and while you're working you
have your kids a lock in a closet
somewhere but in lieu of that somebody
is watching your kids while you're being
the breadwinner right someone has to be
taking care of them it's not you and
especially in Gillibrand's case her job
takes her out of the state for weeks at
a time because she's a lawmaker so
someone has to be caring for your kids
and that
person then would be the primary
caregiver not you think about now we
that was an attack ostensibly on Joe
Biden think about how her husband must
feel imagine if your Gillibrand husband
which would be unfortunate for a number
of reasons but imagine for your husband
and you to not turn on the debate and
here she is in front of a national
audience emasculating you and insulting
you
and essentially implying you do nothing
I mean if your wife is the primary
caregiver and primary breadwinner what
do you do you apparently have no real
function that's that's what Gillibrand
said now it goes without saying of
course that if can you imagine if a man
were to get up at a debate and say hey
listen I earned the money of my family
and I take care of the kids
he would probably be arrested for
domestic abuse the next morning yeah at
a minimum he would have to issue a
groveling apology for for saying
something like that I mean can you
imagine the outrage of a man or to make
that claim about himself but we
encourage in this society we encourage
women to say stuff like this even if
it's not true this is what we encourage
we're you know feminists said hey we
want to go out and and be the
breadwinners that's what feminists have
said for decades and so now many women
do that but they want to have their cake
and eat it too they wanted to have both
they couldn't yeah I'm gonna go be the
breadwinner but because of their
arrogance they they cannot admit that
there's someone else in the family doing
anything so they want to be the primary
breadwinner but they also want to still
lay claim to being the primary caregiver
even though they're out of the house and
somebody else is watching the kids so
that's what you get now I think in our
culture a lot of this supermom stuff
where these women who say I do
everything I know I care for the kids
I'm I I am I am every job I'm a CEO I'm
the teacher i'm the blah blah blah no
you're not you you're not the supermom
you don't do everything there are people
in your and your household who do things
and all we're learning from your
attitude is that you don't appreciate
them you have no appreciation
for them you're ungrateful that's the
only thing we're learning is that the
people who are picking up the slack
because there is some slack because
you're not superhuman what we're
learning is that you have no
appreciation for them so I think we need
to we don't encourage that in men we
don't really encourage men to think or
claim that they do everything in fact we
discourage it yeah we encourage this in
women and I think it's it's damaging
it's damaging to marriages if somebody
in a marriage feels unappreciated feel
feels like they're their contributions
are not being noticed that's deadly to a
marriage and I think that's why a lot of
marriages with feminists don't work out
all right
um let's move on yesterday many on the
Left were celebrating gloating
unapologetically openly after the
Atlantic I believe it was the Atlantic
who first dug up audio from a
conversation nearly 50 years ago so we
are we already did we were doing an
op-ed in 1981 we were talking about that
well let's go back to 1971 let's go back
five decades to a conversation between
the then Governor of California Ronald
Reagan and the then President United
States Richard Nixon Richard Nixon you
know famously had had a thing about
recording people so he recorded the
phone call and the National Archives
five decades later decided to release
this phone call or I believe it was they
had already released parts of the phone
call but they had taken this part out
now they really now they released this
part of it Reagan and and Nixon were
talking about a vote at the UN to
recognize the People's Republic of China
and Reagan was complaining about some of
the African delegates who celebrated the
results he was annoyed by that it
celebrated the vote and this is what he
said about those African delegates
[Music]
if you didn't catch that what he said
was last night I he said last night I
tell you to watch that thing on
television as I did to see those monkeys
from those African countries damn them
they're still uncomfortable wearing
shoes
that's what Reagan said now as I said
the left was pretty ecstatic about this
because of course Reagan was a white
Republican and also he's been an icon on
the right now for decades and and so now
we know he's racist and and there's no
getting around that
right what he said is of course racist
goes without saying racist as hell
actually and repugnant and disgusting so
there's no justifying it or trying today
I wasn't technically racist there's none
of that it was it was racist as as all
get-out but here's my my thing about
this if we're gonna tear down Reagan now
50 years later over something he said
privately and I'm expecting now that the
statutes are gonna come down that his
name's gonna come off buildings and off
of airports which some on the Left have
already been calling for their work they
called for it yesterday immediately is
the first thing they thought is okay
we're take we're taking out yes we can
finally we could we can tear down
another statue of a white person yes
there like I said they were so excited
about it that's the thing about leftists
they are so excited when they discover
that people are racist they love it they
can't get enough of it but if we're
doing that I again have to insist and I
hate to be a stickler I have to again
insist that we do that we be consistent
about this we need to have a consistent
standard a consistent approach to you
know what we do when we discover
skeletons in the closet of people who
died a long time ago you know you've got
a skeleton in the grave because they're
dead and and turns out that the skeleton
has skeletons what do you do when you
find out that a skeleton has skeletons I
think we need to consistent approach
right now the
is not a consistent approach well if
there's any consistency to it it's it
seems to be if we can discover bad
things about a white if the person is
white and conservative or someone who's
important to conservatives are known you
know was known as I could serve it if
they have those two things then we
whatever we find about them we can tear
down their legacy and destroy them
posthumously and kill them all over
again you know that's that seems to be
the standard but I don't I don't think
it's a very fair standard I think we
won't need one that doesn't take race
into consideration the reason I bring
this up you know it just has one example
a few months ago we talked about those
FBI tapes that were reported by a Martin
Luther King jr. the biographer someone
who's a very credible source not not not
some not someone who had a vendetta
against Martin Luther King jr. by any
stretch is someone a biographer someone
who really respected the man but he
reported on tapes that the FBI has of
Martin Luther King jr. that include many
awful things many things far worse
actually than what Reagan said as bad as
that was allegedly they have a tape for
instance of Martin Luther King jr.
laughing as he watches a woman get raped
and then many and then they have tapes
of vital you know when he is committing
violence against women and saying
horrible things about women which
apparently according to these tapes
allegedly he did all the time okay we
talked about that a few few weeks a few
months ago and what I was told
especially by those on the left is that
hey listen it's not it's not relevant it
doesn't he still he still accomplished
what he accomplished why are we digging
this up now this is racist to do this
why are we attacking this this this
great black man it's we can't do that
okay well if that's our standard if
we're saying hey let's let's leave the
dead alone and if somebody has a legacy
for accomplishing great things that
legacy we shouldn't look to undo
or destroy that legacy based on their
own personal flaws if that's what we're
saying about Martin Luther King jr.
which by the way I agree with that
that's what I'm saying about Martin
Luther King jr. this stuff that we know
about him now
allegedly we have to take that into
account we can't ignore it I'm not
saying we ignore it that becomes part of
the story but it doesn't undermine the
fact that Martin Luther King jr.
accomplished great things and was in
many ways a great man but he had
great-great-great flaws so that's what
I'm saying we we think that's how we
look at Martin Luther King jr. now we
don't have to tear down his monuments or
anything like that because those
monuments are there to celebrate what he
did and what he did still was great
well if that's what we're saying about
MLK then I think we have to apply it to
Ronald Reagan or any or any white person
from the past
well Ronald Reagan accomplished great
things not the least of which being
winning the Cold War and so that's one
of the things we celebrate that is not
we can't take that away now that we find
out he said horrible things in private
all right um so let's uh let's do this
then now if you're watching this show a
few days ago somebody alerted me to this
it's from a show called the majority
report with a guy named Sam cedar sader
Center Sadr cedar like the tree I think
I'll just go with cedar anyway Sam who
wants to make it very clear that I am by
the way terrible at my job and
irrelevant and I am just so bad in so
many ways and so stupid and you'll see
he wants to make that very clear it
keeps going back to it yet he still
spent 17 entire minutes of his show a
few days ago responding to comments I
made about the minimum wage which is
always interesting to me when someone
you know responds to me yet also makes
sure to mention that oh but you're
irrelevant but by the way let me let me
respond to everything you're saying now
if you'll excuse the self
we're gonna watch together as Sam plays
clips of me and responds to them and I
have to play the clips of me as well
because or else you won't understand
what he's talking about you probably
won't understand what he's talking about
even with the context but anyway well
well well we'll take a look so let's
let's begin let us find the most moral
amongst us to tell us why people don't
need a minimum wage who do we have that
is the most moral amongst us yet also
has the ability to sound like the oldest
junior high student in the country why
of course it's Matt Walsh on The Daily
wire okay we got to stop it right there
just just for a minute
now if Sam thinks that I'm the most
moral among us well that's his affair
but if if he's implying that I have made
that claim about myself or that I've
even implied that I'm this moral morally
upright person then he's got to provide
examples of that because I don't think
I've ever claimed to be the most moral
or to even be moral at all I don't think
I've ever put myself forward as a moral
example this is something you find a lot
on the left or if you make a moral claim
if you make a moral argument they're
going to automatically accuse you of
being self-righteous and holier than
thou know'st a self what here's what a
self-righteous holier-than-thou person
does a self-righteous holier-than-thou
person puts themselves forward as the
moral example for everyone else to
follow I don't think I've ever done that
ever in my life now if someone has an
example of it they can provide it but
simply making a moral argument doesn't
make yourself right just now here's the
thing what Sam is about to do here is
make a moral critique of me so if making
moral arguments makes you self-righteous
and holier than now then so is Sam
that's so he's already contradicting
himself we're only about 30 seconds and
this is already a mess all right let's
so go back to the clip why of course
it's Matt Walsh on The Daily wire
uh I I do support a minimum wage but the
minimum wage that I support is zero
I think zero is the baseline zero should
be the minimum wage I definitely don't
think the minimum wage it shouldn't go
below that okay so there shouldn't be a
negative
pause nobody should breaking news where
is my breaking news thing
[Music]
daily wire podcast host denounces
slavery there you go
it's pretty big yep breaking news guy
named Sam cedar takes joke literally
well done Sam okay back to the video
zeroes the baseline should be the
baseline wage for work because that's
the baseline amount of effort you can
put in it's possible for someone to do
zero work which means that they have
earned zero dollars do some work it do I
would offer this this that we're
watching assuming he's paid is
disproving his very Theory there because
I feel like we're watching someone who's
put in zero effort or minimal effort but
getting paid far more for it I mean I
feel like he should be paying us to
watch him on some level we're getting
paid to watch it so it's actually
happening the guy just found out what
the minimum wage means but he doesn't
understand it's the minimum wage so it
means the least amount of money that you
can get for working for an hour for
having your labor reserved for that hour
right exactly because you can still fire
people I mean I wonder what I mean Matt
wash thinks about wage theft this is the
opposite of McKee's talking but let's
listen to this because this is
fascinating it really is like I feel
like I understand my Mike my teenage
daughter a little bit better when I
watched this guy work through you have
to warn her against guys like listen Oh
died believe me she knows she knows that
I'm just watching like them like work
through sort of concepts that they don't
seem to be terribly familiar with that's
interesting to me alright a few things
here we're now well it feels like we're
hours into this but we're certainly
several minutes and I haven't heard an
argument have you I haven't heard this
guy explain why I'm wrong you know let
me know if I'm but III if you detected
an argument I let me know I have not yet
detected an argument I've seen a lot of
snorting and snorting and chuckling
snorting combined them was really the
kind of pompous eyebrow raised
oh how foolish how silly this person
doesn't know what they're talking about
I've seen a lot of that but I haven't
seen anything approaching an argument so
just saying over and over and over again
this person is so wrong how wrong they
are
that's not an argument okay my basic
contention is that the minimum wage
should be zero because it's possible for
a person to do zero work okay
my here's to try to make it as simple as
possible so say so even someone like Sam
can understand I believe that when you
do a job you should be paid for the work
you do that a revolutionary I know but
that's that's my that's sort of my
thought process so if you do zero work
for a company then you get zero dollars
if you do a dollars worth of work you
get a dollar if you do fifteen dollars
for the work you get fit that's that's
the way I think it should work you get
paid according to your worth to your
employer as an employee okay it's not
you're not getting paid according to
your worth as a human being we all have
infinite worth as human beings I believe
that as a Christian so but we can't all
get paid in infinity dollars right so
we're gonna get paid according to our
worth as employees now someone yes
someone who's literally worth zero
that's probably someone who's gonna be
fired that's someone who's not going to
have a job anymore so Sam is exactly
right about that so now now I think he's
getting him maybe he's maybe he's
catching on the people who are on the
minimum wage
the real minimum wage in this scenario
are probably going to be the people who
mostly don't have jobs they have zero
worth to any employer thus they have no
job thus their wage in effect is zero
and that's the starting point okay
the least amount you can be worth to an
employer is nothing right what's hard to
understand about this have you ever
heard of the concept of zero Sam it's
possible to be worth nothing to an
employer for instance right now I am as
an employee I am worth nothing to subway
because I don't work for them so I get
paid zero from them I'm worth nothing to
my wage from them is zero all right what
I'm saying is that a minimum wage of
15.7 up well because people like Sam
struggle with it so I feel like I have
to you know he's someone on a remedial
level here which is fine I'm not making
fun of him but so I've got to just slow
down and spell this out for what I'm
saying is that a minimum wage of $15 an
hour doesn't make sense because it
assumes it commands really that every
person who has a job must necessarily be
worth at least $15 an hour to their
employer just by the fact that they
exist and they walk in the door I don't
think that's the case so Sam of course
goes for another person will dig there
as you saw says that I'm worth a zero to
my employer but again not an argument
that's just an insult a lame one and
here's the thing Sam it's also not our
accurate because I'm I'm not worth the
zero at the my employer I'm not I'm not
even worth the zero to you because
you're using me for content
I'm not worth zero to my employer and in
this business it's pretty easy for my
employer to tell what I'm worth because
they can look at traffic they look at ad
revenue they can look at the size of my
platform so on and so forth and
according to all of that I am worth more
than zero at least you might not like
that you might not like me you might
think I should be worth as Europe you
might think I'm a terrible person that's
fine
and maybe that's all true but it doesn't
matter you know because I bring in money
to my employer and so therefore I'm
worth money to them that's all it's a
it's a transactional relationship that's
all it is that's how it works again a
simple concept and then I thought it was
interesting there in that clip there he
goes and he he goes on to insult me by
comparing me to his teenage daughter a
great dad this guy is he uses
comparisons to his teenage daughter as
an insult okay wonderful man isn't he
now I got to tell you say you know I'm
sure your teenage daughter is a
wonderful person so I don't take that as
an insult you apparently are you know
have a low opinion over I I don't I
don't know her but I'm sure she's
wonderful so I you know I'm
I'll take that as a compliment actually
okay now we're gonna go back to a clip
of me and and his response this is me
first
talking about a kind of typical
experience I had interacting with
somebody at a fast-food restaurant who
in my view and I was trying to
illustrate just with a personal
experience one that we've all had so you
know it's not not anything unique and
that's the point but I'm trying to
illustrate how a person might be worth
less than $15 and so let's go to that
clip and so here's how that interaction
work that interaction went verbatim and
as I said we've all had interactions
like this so I walk up the cashier he
goes did I help you yes I'll have the
large number one please thank you Big
Mac that it yes that's 657 actually
sorry can you can you change that to a
medium okay posit I want to remind you
he's being paid for this being paid
money for this isn't this a good but
here's an interesting thing now now
let's just stop here because this this
would also blow his mind
that that meal number one for 657 that
means that that meal according to Matt
Walsh you can't find that meal at a
different price anywhere else in the
country right because prices are fixed
there has to be let there has to be more
or less value on that okay I'm confused
here how do you get from my argument
about the minimum wage that I therefore
think you can't get fast food for less
than 650 so that doesn't even make any
sense I think Sam is spiraling into just
nonsense at this point but let's let's
see if we can find some kind of argument
so let's keep watching
he's saying that his service is not
worth $15 an hour or is not worth the
person who gave him service the one who
treated him nicely it's at McDonald's I
mean give me a break the
that this guy could make $1 more than
zero or any more than like half the
people that we watch the stuff even
stuff that we disagree with this is bad
they're just from an entertainment
perspective it's bad it's bad
it's I know I'm making money mocking it
and it's still painful blows my mind
that he would think that he doesn't come
off like the worst person in the world
in this the the point is is that he is
proving maybe maybe it's some type of
art project but he's proving that the
value of labor is completely subjective
okay you know see I think Sam what you
what you're proving is that a person can
hit the age of 50 without developing the
ability to understand simple concepts
and I go back and I ask the listener
again have you heard an argument yet has
there been an argument all I've heard
from this is that I'm bad I'm terrible
I'm just like his daughter who would be
apparently isn't fond of I'm just awful
I'm bad this is how this is how Sam
argues and listen there are a lot of
people on the Left who argue like this
so this is how say much you make your
point you say I think X Y Z because ABC
and Sam's counter-argument you're bad
you're just bad you're so bad you're bad
you're bad bad bad bad bad so bad my god
and this guy I think he's in his 50s and
this is the I mean and again Sam the
reason I'm worth more than zero to mine
so more than zero more than a dollar
really is that I myself make money from
my employer
even if I'm bad even if I'm the worst
person in the world talentless terrible
stupid evil doesn't matter that's the
point I make money for my employer and
so I get paid that's the equation that's
it
you make money for your employer and you
get paid if you make money for your
employer and you don't get paid then
yeah that's
wage theft that's wrong but if you're
put in the effort and you're makin the
money then you get paid and you should
get paid according to how much you know
how how much you're worth your employer
my contention about that fast-food
worker is that based on the effort and
the skill he brings to the table his
financial worth to his employer is
minimal and the reason it's minimal is
that almost anyone could do what he does
almost anyone could replace him they
could fire him and there's a 99% chance
that whoever walks in the door next
however old they are they could be 6
years old they could do what that guy
does so he's just not worth that much
financially to his employer and and
importantly here the automated things
that McDonald's that they already have
set up that thing can do what that guy
does and do it better actually now that
could change here's the good news he has
the power to change it he could come to
work tomorrow energetic on the ball
helpful involved engaged on time ready
to work you know making the customers
feel good upselling doing all this stuff
that he could do that tomorrow and
instantly just like that in an instant
he could be worth considerably more than
a dollar an hour he has that power he
has that ability so that's that's the
that's the upside to all of this ok
let's see let's let's go let's see if we
can find him really gonna play one more
clue because I'm really looking for an
argument of some kind we still haven't
gotten one and let's go here this is the
closest thing to an argument were gonna
get now here it is the more they talk
about how people don't deserve a living
wage the more they insulate themselves
they will gain no new voters from this
and they will just remind people that
the Democratic Party is the one who is
ensuring that at the very least there is
a minimum wage that the idea that you
set aside an hour to work and go work
and create value beyond your wages
other people and it's true we there will
be some job loss because of this in
summits there has to be some but the
revenue generated will create other jobs
okay and that's and that's as I said
that's it really
as far as arguments go they they he goes
into more personal insults a little bit
later on he says that my bookshelf is
ugly and really that's that's that's
part of his rebuttal is that I have an
ugly bookshelf which you can't see right
now because I'm at the studio but and
and I will say I think book shops
shelves should be ugly you know they
should be cluttered that's what a
bookshelf should look meanwhile his
backdrop looks like a stained glass
window an Episcopal Church from like
1975 but never mind that
he says that everyone deserves a living
wage okay not really an argument that's
more of an assertion but it's the best
we're gonna do so I'll deal with that
it's a nice sentiment okay that's
something that you can shout and and
people will nod their heads and he's
right about that voters love it and
that's that's fine
but who cares because I'm not running
for office I'm not a Republican
politician running for office so I don't
care I'm not I'm not up here trying to
say things that the voters are gonna
like I'm just telling you the truth as I
see it and that's why I have no problem
saying I have no problem saying and this
is not my recommendation to Republican
politicians that they should say this
the way that I'm going to say it but I
have no problem saying no not everybody
deserves a living wage in fact if I
could give you just one example of a
person hypothetically who wouldn't
deserve a living wage then I have
defeated I have disproven the thesis
that everyone deserves a living wage
okay so let's take someone who we evoke
a person the kind of person that we've
all come across at our jobs
let's take someone who comes into work
late every day gossips about their
fellow employees puts an absolute bare
minimum effort is rude to the customers
is unreliable and so on ok does that
person deserve a living wage if so how
based on
what I mean what do you mean they
deserve why
where'd where does that come from there
does this deserving nature they have
where does it come from Sam does it just
come from the it doesn't come from them
from the job they're doing because the
job is crap job they're doing is crap
so it just comes from just because
they're them from the very fact that
they're a body walking into a building I
don't think it works that way what about
someone who steals from the cash
register do they deserve a living wage
well no okay so we can fire them right
so that's fine okay so so that's someone
who doesn't deserve a living wage right
so we have now come to the conclusion
that it's possible theoretically for a
person to not deserve a living wage okay
now we're getting somewhere well is it
possible that a living wage is something
you earn not something you deserve
simply for existing simply because
you're a warm body but it's something
you earn that's that's my contention and
I will say this everyone who has earned
a living wage deserves a living wage
so again wage theft if you've earned a
certain salary and your senior employer
is not giving it to you that's theft
they're stealing from you that's wrong
I'm against that
and here's the great thing and I just
have to emphasize this the type of
person I outlined who doesn't deserve a
living wage here's what's really great
they can deserve it they could deserve
it tomorrow
just like that they they can deserve it
by earning it and they can make that
change immediately
especially at a job like McDonald's all
these fast-food places because if you if
you put in an effort that is slightly
above bare minimum and you do things
like if you work at a place like
McDonald's or and I've worked these jobs
so this is how I know that this then if
you do radical things like tuck in your
shirt come
to work on time every day be willing to
take on extra shifts smile to the
customers you do really basic stuff like
that you've already set yourself above
probably 80% of your co-workers so
someone who I would if you if you
pointed them to me right now a person
that I would say no they don't deserve a
living wage that's not a death sentence
that's not a life sentence that that
could change in the next 30 seconds if
they just changed the way that they
approach their job and they become worth
more to their employer in doing that you
know I also gave the example of the you
know you go to some of these places
sometimes and yeah we have we can
sometimes run into those customer
service people who are terrible but then
also sometimes you run into those
customer service people who are just
amazing and are so on the ball have so
much energy are so nice and friendly
that they make you want to order more
they make you want to come back they
make you feel good it is if you're if
you're a customer and you're going into
a retail place or a restaurant if you
feel good you're gonna buy more stuff
and that's why the company wants you to
feel good as so if as an employee if
you're making the customers feel good
then you're worth a lot to your employer
and that's why I say you get rid of the
minimum wage this whole I think
fallacious idea that everybody is worth
at least X amount regardless of the work
they do you get rid of that then you
have could have a scenario where you've
got five people working behind a you
know the counter McDonald's yeah a few
of them are making four or five bucks an
hour because that's all they were but
you've also got people making twenty
five bucks an hour because they're so
good at what they do and you enable the
companies to reward the people who are
really doing a great job
that's my contention I don't think Sam
did anything to Demong kit or disprove
it so a rather pitiful performance there
unfortunately and again I give my
condolences to his daughter we you know
insults publicly which is which is also
unfortunate all right we're we're not
gonna have time to
emails again today but email me and Matt
wall show at gmail.com and I promise
tomorrow we'll we'll get into the
mailbag but we'll end it here today
thanks everybody for watching Godspeed
dark psychic forces dominated our
national political debate over the past
two days as 20 Democrat want to be
presidents took the stage in Detroit to
humiliate themselves we will examine the
best of the worst with a special
emphasis on breakout star Marianne
Williamson then the mailbag check it out
at the Michael Knowles show